All right,
so I'm looking at the pimsleur website
right now.
Uh,
this is the,
this is the page for pimsleur French,
and this looks really good.
I think I'm going to buy this.
So let's check the price.
Uh,
what's that?
Well,
here's the price in pesos.
I wonder how much it is in dollars.
Uh,
wait,
that's dollars.
Hello folks,
this is Paul.
How you doing today?
I've decided to make this video to give
you a review about a language program
called pimsleur.
Pimsleur.
French is the one I wanted to focus on.
I've done some other pimsleur courses.
I've done the,
I did one level of Arabic right now I'm
using tagalog.
Uh,
I did one level of Hebrew wants,
but the one that I've gone through the
most is French.
I've did four levels of French.
There are five levels now that I've done
four of them,
so I thought I'm in the best position to
keep that one in mind and focus on that
one.
Uh,
so pimsleur,
right there are five levels.
It's quite good.
Um,
I like it but I think it's quite
expensive and that seems to be one of
the common complaints is just the price,
like it's a,
it's a good quality program to learn the
basic skills of a language,
but it's just really expensive.
So if you buy a cds like levels one to
five would be like 150 cds because
there's 30 CCS per level.
If you bought them all on cd,
that would be,
I think about $1,200
us.
So quite a lot of money,
right?
You can get them in digital format and
MP for about $550,
I believe it was the price.
So less than half price for digital
format.
So you can get that discount and I don't
recommend buying the CDS.
Why would you buy the cds in 2015 when
you can just get the MP three downloads
for less than half the price.
So I'll do that.
Or if you're a friend or someone happens
to have the cds,
maybe you can borrow them if you feel
ethically okay with that.
And if you're not worried about Simon
and Schuster coming to hunt you down and
borrow them,
I don't know,
find a way,
but it's good,
but it's expensive.
That's kind of the main thing I wanted
to start with.
But let's talk about what's good.
I'll give you my kind of sandwich
format.
I'll give you the good than the
imperfect and then kind of wind up with
the good and maybe a suggestion on how
to use it.
So,
um,
the good things first,
one good thing is just that it's an all
audio program and it really gets you
familiar with the phonology of the
language and the sounds of the language.
And I'm big on that.
I really think it's important at the
beginning when you learn a language to
really get down the phonology.
I think that's what I'm,
that's what helps you sync in that
language is what is really getting the
phonology down.
That's kind of the access to the inner
core of the language,
the culture of the language.
Pimsleur helps you do that because
you're,
you're immersed in the sounds right from
the beginning and you're not relying on
the visual input.
You're kind of forced to listen to the
sounds and make sense of them audibly
without having that visual input of
reading.
So it's really good for that.
Uh,
so that's one thing and it does it in a
way that also drills the sentence
structure.
So you're not just like listening and
repeating to sounds or phrases or
sentences.
It's actually building up piece by
piece.
Uh,
it's,
it's really structured in a way that
helps you to build progressively more
difficult sentences as you go.
Another good thing about pimsleur is
that it uses something called graduated
intervals,
which is one of the features that it's
famous for.
I guess a graduated intervals means that
you learn some language,
like a vocabulary or phrase or a
structure.
Then you review it soon after,
after a short interval of time,
but then the next time you review it,
the interval of time gets a little
longer and then the next time you review
it,
there's a little bit longer between the
reviews.
So the amount of time between each,
uh,
each review,
each time you are asked to recall that
language gets greater and greater.
So that's good for,
for basically I'm internalizing it into
your longterm memory.
The more times that you review that,
that language,
the less frequently you have to review
it.
That's basically the point.
If you're familiar with Hunky
flashcards,
they use something,
a similar system to that where I'm the
spaced repetition software.
If you get the card right,
then the next time you see it is after a
greater interval.
If you get the card wrong or you are not
confident about it,
then you see it after a shorter
interval.
That's something similar to graduated
intervals.
Another good thing is that it gets you
just to repeat things a lot,
like you're repeating the same
structures in the same boat,
a basic vocabulary over and over and
over,
and when you're first learning a
language,
it's important to do that.
To repeat things over a lot,
to get some automaticity to get things
internalized to the point where you can
say them without really thinking,
especially for structures like basic
sentence structures.
That's good because you get those
structures that come out automatically
and then you can substitute vocabulary
and make new sentences that you've never
made before.
So,
uh,
it,
it drills a lot of that kind of thing.
It gets you repeating a lot,
but it does it in a way that always
seems like you're learning something
new.
Okay.
So onto some of the things that are
imperfect or things that I need,
I think needs to be supplemented or
whatever.
Um,
I don't think that the audio only is
always sufficient.
There are always some times in a
pimsleur course where I can't clearly
hear what the speaker is saying on the
CDS.
Uh,
I think everyone perceives sounds a
little bit differently and there are
sounds that you might be able to
perceive for easily that I hear them and
I can't quite hear what they're saying.
I just don't know what letters those
would come out to if written down or I
just,
I can't imagine what the word is.
I can't really perceive the sounds.
Uh,
and in those kind of situations they
don't really.
They don't know which sounds I'm not
perceiving.
So they don't clarify it,
so I can't really stick to the pimsleur
philosophy of only listened to the CD,
only use the audio in that kind of
situation.
So I break their rules and I reached for
my dictionary and look up a word that
sounds like what they're saying or I'll
pause it and I'll try to find,
find out what the word is.
Um,
but I,
I need to use some kind of visual input.
Um,
having the visual input in that kind of
situation is really helpful because if
you can't perceive the sound once you
see it,
then you can perceive it because you'll
be connecting that mysterious sound with
something visual.
Right?
Uh,
so I,
I don't buy the whole audio only thing,
100 percent.
I think it's really good to have a focus
on audio,
especially in the beginning in that
solves a lot of the problems of
traditional learning using just books
without a lot of audio or like a book
with just one CD or whatever.
Um,
but I think it's still good to have some
visual input.
So I think it's good to do this,
to do pimsleur in conjunction with other
more visual materials.
Another thing is that you just never
quite learn as much as you think you're
going to learn.
Uh,
I think partly that's because people
look at the size of the course,
like,
Whoa,
150 cds for five levels,
or even just like the first two levels.
Wow,
that's 60 cds.
If I finished 60 cds of French,
I'm gonna have to be fluent,
right?
That's 60 whole cds of French.
I'm going to have to be really,
really good after that.
Or they look at the price and they say,
wow,
okay,
it's a thousand dollars for five levels.
Uh,
I,
that must make me fluent that better
make me fluent.
So I'm spending a lot of money on that.
But it doesn't really work like that.
It gives you a good basis,
a good basic understanding and a good
basic anchoring in speaking,
listening,
and interactive skills.
It gives you a good basis to build on.
But it's not gonna make you fluent.
So basically I think pimsleur is really
good.
The only problem I have with it is the
price,
I just think it's too expensive.
Uh,
I know a lot of work goes into it and
they can charge whatever they want,
but just a lot of people can't really
afford to buy all the levels.
So that's the,
that's what it is.
It's the price,
but it's good.
It's good quality.
I think it's good for building up your,
your listening and your speaking and
your oral communication skills without
relying on the visual too much.
So that solves some of those problems of
traditional learning we had with just
focusing on written materials too much,
focusing on the visual input too much
and not being able to translate that
into conversations.
Pimsleur is kind of one of the ways you
can solve that problem.
Um,
but I don't think pimsleur alone is
enough.
I think you need to supplement it with
visual input.
Um,
even at the same time while you're doing
pimsleur,
pimsleur advises you against that.
I don't believe that I,
uh,
I think you should,
you should supplement with visual
materials.
Use a textbook,
um,
you know,
read a authentic materials,
try to use as much visual input as you
can.
Use other sources,
not just the audio,
right in a top of that,
the audio on the pimsleur cds is
controlled,
right?
It's controlled practice.
It's,
there's a lot of repeating,
there's a lot of,
um,
uh,
there's a lot of just question and
answer type of a type of structure.
So it's,
it's really limited in what you hear and
what you're expected to produce.
So you need to have experienced from the
beginning in uncontrolled situations,
free practice,
right?
Uh,
that means talk with native speakers in
a context that's not really laid out,
that where you're just conversing and
trying to communicate and figuring out
how to say things.
And you can do that by getting a
teacher,
like a tutor on Italki through skype.
You can take lessons or if someone in
your town speaks that language and they
can tutor you or help you out,
you can get a language partner and do a
language exchange,
something like that.
And then use that as your opportunity to
practice communicating.
And then when there's a communication
breakdown or there's like a language
barrier that can help you get through
that,
but telling you,
oh,
in this situation we say this and
whatever.
So you learn how to deal with those
unexpected natural situations that come
up in real conversations that you won't
get on the pimsleur cds.
So you need to supplement,
you need the visual input and you also
need that free practice.
Um,
and if you do the,
all those things in conjunction with the
Pimsleur,
then you're going to come up with a
really strong base and when you're done
the courses,
you'll be ready to get into some simple
conversations and then build more and
more on top of that.
So pimsleur is good.
The price,
I don't know what to say about it,
but try to get your hands on them,
use them,
but supplement.
It's not the only thing to use,
but it's good.
Wow.